Der kopfhörer ist eines der begehrtesten technik gadgets überhaupt durch den siegeszug der smartphones
Ist er das trendprodukt der letzten jahre insbesondere
Drahtlose tonübertragung per bluetooth und noise cancelling also die auslöschung von
Störendem schalk sind der heiße scheiß ich habe mal fünf der begehrten exemplare genauer unter die lupe genommen und ich erklären wie das ganze
Genau funktioniert und am ende erfährt, er welche kopfhörer die nase vorn hat war ein klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Ich stelle euch vor den eleganten libra
turnier den für seine beste berühmten beats studio 3 wireless
Den beau sind gut 35 vom erfinder, des noise cancelling es den sennheiser pcx
550 von einem der audio unternehmen in deutschland und den sony
Bh 1000x m2 aber erstmal gibt es etwas know how auf die ohren?
Stellen wir uns mal ganz dumm also audio also ton das ist ja nichts anderes als schallwellen
Also, so kann man sie dargestellt aber genau genommen sind es gar keine wellen sondern es ist die durch wellenmuster
darstellbare
komprimierung und die komprimierung von luft das bringt dann unser trommelfell
Genau in diesen rhythmus wie der schall darauf trifft zum schwingen so kann man eine schallwelle darstellen
Genau wie die musik die wir hören wollen treffen auch störgeräusche als solche
Schallwellen auf unser ohr die schallwellen der störgeräusche sollen jetzt aber zerstört werden aber wie dazu
Gehen wir mal in die vergangenheit der tonübertragung
Denn da gab es schon mal so etwas das ist ein
Symmetrisches ton kabel es überträgt den ton auf zwei leitungen und da machte es etwas
Um störgeräusche zu unterdrücken zum beispiel die von stromkabeln die brummen nämlich mit 50 hertz
Lustig vor sich hin und stören so ein parallel laufendes ton kabel 50 hertz ist die frequenz mit der plus und minuspol beim wechsel
Stromkabel wechseln 50 mal pro sekunde ist hier und mal hier plus oder minus was passiert jetzt also wann
symmetrischen kabel das ist einfach und ziemlich genial auf der einen seite wird das signal normal übertragen und auf der anderen seite
genau andersrum also
Worum die schallwelle wird quasi gespiegelt würde man jetzt am ende die beiden kabel einfach zusammen schalten
wird etwas total irre es passieren die schallwellen würden sich gegenseitig auslöschen
also das hier passiert sie ergeben 0
Man würde einfach nichts mehr hören stille nur die störgeräusche würde man noch hören wie zb das brummen eines daneben liegenden
Stromkabels aber jetzt wird etwas noch
mal genial jahres gemacht die gespiegelten schall werden werden widergespiegelt und löschen sich also nicht mehr
Aus also das wird klasse wieder hoch gelegt. Also das ganze, sieht jetzt so aus hier
Ist das ein signal und das andere wird jetzt einfach dazu gelegt
Mit den störgeräuschen passiert jetzt aber folgendes sie die vorher
Diese beiden wellen überlagert haben
Die sind ja auf beiden wellen gleich also hier ist genau das gleiche
störgeräusche wie
auf dieser welle
Und jetzt könnt ihr euch schon vorstellen was passiert wenn
man das ganze umdreht
Was passiert mit den störgeräuschen die auf den beiden wellen sind
da passiert nämlich jetzt folgendes die
Werden ja jetzt andersherum zusammengelegt nämlich so und die löschen sich jetzt gegenseitig aus einfach aber genial
Störgeräusche sind absolut nicht mehr zu hören und so können auf konzerten
Im tonstudio und sonst wo die kabel komplett durcheinander liegen neben
stromkabeln
starkstromkabel und
anderen störquellen und nichts ist dann davon zu hören eine absolut simple und geniale erfindung aber eigentlich
Müsste das ja auch, mit dem schall selbst funktionieren also nicht nur elektronisch sondern auch akustisch die firma bose testete
1986 den ersten kopfhörer mit active noise cancelling drei jahre später
Konnten sie dann gekauft werde zunächst waren sie nur für flugzeugpiloten gedacht weil neues cancelling hier deutlich praktischen nutzen brachte
Und die piloten so viel besser per funk und auch untereinander sprechen konnten das prinzip ist ähnlich wie beim kabel nur
Unendlich viel komplizierter hier muss der ton erst mal außerhalb. Des kopfhörers mit einem oder mehreren mikrofonen
Aufgefangen werden aus diesen hall wellen muss dann ein signal errechnet werden dass die dämmung des
kopfhörers und den weg zum trommelfell genau
Berücksichtigt da jedes ohr anders ist und auch jeder kopfhörer kommt es hierbei dem algorithmus
Extrem auf das know how des herstellers haben nicht umsonst gilt
als einer der besten hersteller für noise cancelling kopfhörer dieses signal wird dann wieder gespiegelt
zusätzlich der musik signal
hinzugefügt und löscht die störgeräusche aus wie gut dass die verschiedenen hersteller können das werden wir jetzt sehen beziehungsweise hören
Dann, heben wir uns mal den kopfhörer das noise cancelling erfinders bose für den schluss auf aber erst mal die übersicht wir
Haben uns angesehen den beats studio 3 weil es für etwa 320
240 euro den sony wh 1000x m2 für rund 300 euro
den lepra
Turnier den gibt es schon 470 euro dann den sennheiser pcx
550 4
250 bis 280 euro und den bose pc 35 430 oder fangen wir mal mit dem preiswerten debra
Tokyo electron er an er unterscheidet sich von allen anderen durch sign on ihr design aus der tragekomfort kann hier je nach
etwas
Eingeschränkt sein da der kopfhörer etwas auf die ohren drückt da er keine ohrpolster
Art die den druck von den rohren abhalten und er hat noch einen nachteil die bedienung muss man sich merken
Kreisförmige bewegungen lauter und leiser play und pause jeweils ein mal tippen genau so nimmt man einen
telefonanruf an oder beendeten und mit zwei mal tippen kommt man zum nächsten titel noise cancelling und das finde ich sehr praktisch
Kann in vier stufen mit dieser taste ausgewählt werden je nachdem wie viel man noch von
Außen hören möchte das noise cancelling funktioniert dabei tadellos wobei es als offener kopfhörer nicht ganz so effektiv ist wie
bei, einem geschlossenen kopfhörer die akkulaufzeit beim libra ton ist ganz ordentlich
22 stunden da gehe ich mal drei punkte
der sound bei einem libretto ncua depp ist ordentlich eigentlich aber er kann nicht ganz mit den geschlossenen
kopfhörer mithalten deshalb für den sound beim libra tokio hat nur zwei punkte
Jakober zum sennheiser ein wirklich sehr sehr guter kopfhörer tragekomfort
1a passt perfekt zumindest offen meine ohren der sound ist absolut spitze beim sennheiser
Da geben sich drei kopfhörer eigentlich nichts in diesem test er ist einer von
Den drei spitzenreitern allerdings beim noise cancelling liegt, er nur im mittelfeld
Ich gebe ihm drei punkte wobei man. Sagen muss die liegen alle alle sehr dicht beieinander
bei der akkulaufzeit
Gehört der sennheiser zu den absoluten spitzenreitern also fast ist er der beste
30 stunden das ist schon eine menge vier punkte ja das ist der witz
Wenn man den auspackt dann erfährt man dir zu bedienen ist dass
Er mir aufkleber drauf allerdings wenn man dann hat dann muss man sich merken wir zu bedienen ist ja
knallrot legende die beats der
tragekomfort auch hier
spitzenklasse und
Beim sound da gehört er nicht zur spitzenklasse das sind andere kopfhörer er ist so ein bisschen
mulmig verschwommen nicht
So klar wie unsere
spitzenreiter deshalb drei punkte für den sound von beats studio 3 wireless
Beim noise cancelling da ist er eher hinten dran das muss man sagen er ist sogar schlechter als der offene
liberation cueva
Und ist wirklich am hinteren ende
Allerdings war muss. Sagen es ist subjektives hängt auch von den eigenen ohren ab aber ich persönlich würde wenn es
Um die störgeräusche und darum geht einen anderen kopfhörer wählen akkulaufzeit dagegen. Im mittelfeld drei punkte 22
Stunden das ist ganz okay kommen wir zum sony
ein absolut schickes stück muss man sagen und
Er. Gehört auch zu den absoluten spitzenreitern, im klang und er
Und er redet mit einem nein
Absolut klarer sound
Für. Mich subjektiv alle frequenzen ordentlich vertreten
Sauber und ich bin absolut super dazu kommt auch noch
tragekomfort
Auch absolut perfekt zumindest für meine ohren und das noise cancelling ist hier
absolute spitzenklasse das liegt auch mit sicherheit daran dass man ihn auf seine
ohren kalibrieren kann das heißt er misst die unterschiede die es bei den verschiedenen ohren gibt und kann so
Beurteilen wie der schall sich im gehörgang
Bewegt um daraufhin die unterdrückung der störgeräusche
abzustimmen aber andersrum ist er der schlechteste
kopfhörer wenn wir ihn mit allen anderen vergleichen selbst verglichen mit dem libretto ncua der ja offen ist dieser kopfhörer lässt am
Meisten der musik die man hört nach
Außen das ist natürlich ein nachteil deswegen nur einen punkt wer also in der u-bahn s-bahn
im zug
Im flugzeug niemanden stören will ist mit diesem kopfhörer nicht optimal bedient kommt natürlich auf die musik an die man hört aber
es könnte schwierig werden und nochmal absolute höchstpunktzahl für den sony fünf punkte für die akkulaufzeit
32 stunden das ist die beste
Akkulaufzeit, des testfeldes also mit dem kann man schon ein paar tage zu bringen der bose absolute legende vom erfinder des
Noise cancelling es deswegen hier unser letzter test kandidat tragekomfort wie bei allen geschlossenen kopfhörer
absolut optimal da drückt nichts
und auch nach stunden wird man
Den kopfhörer nicht auf den ohren der sound auch absolute spitzenklasse klar kompletter
frequenzbereich starke bässe mitten höhen alles ist da
Ich finde man kann mit dem alle arten von musik ganz toll hören ich habe von orgelmusik
funktioniert der zu den schwierigsten kandidaten gehört das ist alles glasklar aber
Akkulaufzeit der bose ist das absolute schlusslicht mit 17 stunden ich kann nur sagen
geht man eure
entwicklungsabteilung macht da was dran deshalb nur zwei punkte für den busen bei der akkulaufzeit ja noise cancelling und das ist wirklich ein bisschen
Frappierend da ist er nicht der absolute top spitzenkandidat wie gesagt die gegen alle sehr dicht beieinander
Aber ich würde sagen der böse ist nicht ganz so gut wie der sony der hier wirklich
Absolute spitzenklasse ist und alles weg hält der bose außengeräusche ja
Nicht das absolute highlight aber auch nicht, am ende
Des testfeldes drei punkten gutes mittelfeld mann sollte es mal ausprobieren vielleicht mal mit freunden in den
elektronikmarkt gehen und da auch selbst
Vergleichen wer bei der eigenen musik es kommt auch darauf an was man an musik hört bei techno kann es durchaus bei dem ein oder
Anderen kopfhörer schwierig werden wie gesagt der pause im mittelfeld
Wir testen die kopfhörer mit zwei geräuschen die wir hier hinten auf der stereoanlage
Abspielen und gucken wie stark sie den ton
abhalten von den ohren also diese äußeren störgeräusche geräusch eines der worte
Bahnhof in london
Ja ganz gutes neues cancelling ist kommen noch ein paar geräusche hier bei der bahnstation durch hochfrequente vor allen dingen
Auch sehr gutes neues
Also hier würde ich sagen auch die tiefen und geräusche alle weg noch ein paar hohe stimmen
Der ist gegenüber dem sennheiser und dem beats
auch im hochfrequenten bereich deutlich wirkungsvoller also man hat das gefühl dass neues cancelling geht über mehr frequenzen
Verrückt obwohl der libration offen ist ungefähr ähnliche noise cancelling wirkung wie beim pose
Ich würde sagen noise cancelling ist beim sony tatsächlich am besten wirklich dicht und über den gesamten frequenzbereich
hierbei der waterloo station geräusch 2 ein einfaches maschinen geräusch von der stehenden u-bahn
Ähnlich wie bei der waterloo station beim beats hohe töne kommen noch durch tiefe werden herausgefiltert
auch bei diesen dauerhaften maschinengeräusche mein subjektiver eindruck beim sennheiser etwas besser als der beats
Auch der bose bei dem maschinengeräusche, hohe frequenzen kommen noch leicht durch
Während der lieber dom bei der bahn station noch mit dem bose fast gleichauf lag hier bei einem kontinuierlichen geräusch ist er etwas schwächer
Und beim sony würde ich sagen bei diesem kontinuierlichen geräusche kommen die mittleren frequenzen etwas besser durch insgesamt muss man sagen
Bei
Allen kopfhörern die unterschiede sind beim noise cancelling minimal es hängt glaube ich auch extrem
Von den eigenen ohren um vom gehörgang ab wie stark das noise cancelling bei einem selbst wirkt man sollte sich also
mal anhören unter realen bedingungen in den
elektronikmärkten ist ja meistens auch ein ganz gutes
Hintergrundgeräusch da kann man das ganz gut testen die unterschiede sind auf jeden fall
Minimal aber sie sind signifikant und man sollte sich das glaube ich wirklich selbst anleihen und wir haben uns noch ein ganz besonderer test
Ausgedacht die geräusche die nach. Außen bringen. Also die musik die nach, außen dringt der kopfhörer die haben wir in der berliner u-bahn getestet
Ja der liebert rompuy der schalt schon ein bisschen aus man hört ein bisschen aber der preis ist unschlagbar
Ja da ist der witz wirklich unschlagbar kaum etwas dringt nach draußen von der musik die man, so hört. Also der ideale
begleiter in der öffentlichkeit
Ja wer hätte das gedacht
Beim sony dringen die meisten
Geräusche nach, draußen also die in anderen passagiere hören am meisten von der musik die man. Hört techno ist da vielleicht nicht so geeignet
Super klang aber da ist er wirklich nicht der beste sondern ist am ende
unserer testreihen
Tatsächlich ist der böse einigermaßen dicht aber
mittelfeld muss man sagen man bekommt schon etwas bei lauter musik mehr mit als bei anderen kopfhörern
Muss man wissen wenn man diesen kopfhörer kauft
Der sennheiser da muss man sagen das ist unsere nummer 2 was die schall
Tätigkeiten angeht und bekommt kaum etwas mit von dem was man hört was vielleicht auch an den weichen polstern liegt
Die auch sehr angenehm sind also
top in dieser kategorie ja das ist unser testergebnis erst mal ich glaube einer der
Entscheidenden gründe um kopfhörer zu kaufen ist natürlich der sound da sind hier bose sennheiser und sony die absoluten
spitzenreiter wichtig natürlich auch hier noise cancelling auch hier hinten ist er das spitzenfeld wobei der
libration unser ja preissieger quasi ja auch ziemlich gut aussieht was ich noch für ein wichtiges kriterium
Halte ist wie viel geräusch wie für musik dringt nach außen
auch da die unterschiede sind nicht riesig aber sie können dann doch für den ein oder anderen entscheidend seien hier
der sony ansonsten wirklich unser bester kopfhörer bei unserem rein subjektiven test sage ich natürlich
Ist da nicht so stark wie ein beats der aber
Im klang wieder nicht
So toll ist also es gibt verschiedene kriterien überlegt selbst guckt euch an testet die links, zu allen kopfhörern die gibt es natürlich
unten in der video beschreibung
Klick drauf informiert euch noch. Näher und ja wenn er einen lieb gewonnen habt dann greift
Zu ja wenn ihr kein video von klicks und verpassen wollt dann würde ich mal sagen drückt mir hier ein abo aufs auge
vergesst nicht den
Auf die glocke denn nur dann werdet ihr über neue videos informiert hier geht es weiter
Mit den zehn top erfolgsfaktoren um erfolgreich auf youtube zu werden und ansonsten würde ich mal sagen bis dann
bleibt dran